[Music]
[Applause]
you know yesterday afternoon I took a
trip to flavor town by the way it's
different zip codes but there was a
flavor Town locally here in Connecticut
and uh I thought I killed it you know I
did I was co-host with Guy Fieri Diners
Drive-Ins and Dives and he is probably
calling to offer me up the permanent gig
as the co-host for Diners Drive-ins
Dives and Dan so uh guy uh thanks for
joining us and uh thanks again for
yesterday uh I'm I can help you if you
need some help
well you you stole the show you know you
did you stole the show uh you stole the
uh the lamb shank and uh you stole the
car yeah so I'm calling about the keys
where are you now
I'm in uh I'm in Greenwich at a great
pizza joint I can't tell you the name of
it because they're already busy as can
be uh but we're shooting triple D here
again and everybody is asking where you
are and I said probably late again yeah
but I I did show up I thought that it
was a nice Cameo I was a little nervous
though because you were speaking a
different language if it was Sports then
I'm okay but you're talking about you
know herbs and spices from Greece and
you're talking about whole carrots and
rock Lavon I mean I'm going uh just get
the food out of the damn oven so I can
eat it
you I well you could tell everybody that
you sounded nervous and that but you
were I actually and it was really a
blast I mean you're such a pro at what
you do you folded into it incredibly
well matter of fact with my team when
you left we all looked at and said that
was just too short we needed to do a
whole a whole series of it so we need
you again and really was it was a blast
and you know I'm a fan of you and fan of
the show but dude you were hysterical I
mean and guys he caught on so quick and
we moved fast I mean we shoot really
quick and you were uh you're in the
pocket buddy at one point the you know
guys just talking to the chef I don't
know we're on camera I don't know
they're recording even though I should
have seen the red light hello and all of
a sudden I realized that they're
actually recording this so I didn't say
anything stupid at least I tried not to
but give people an idea of how long it
takes to shoot an episode of Diners
Drive-Ins and Dives
well fortunately like you I have a great
team so my team does the the Advance on
the on the restaurant a day ahead of
time so they get a chance to shoot all
the b-roll and kind of get the chefs and
the team warmed up on what's going to
happen then I come in
um and we do everything from making the
dishes to tasting them to meeting the
you know meeting the guests and getting
their profile and then doing the stand
up which by the way that's the intro of
the show the stand up with Dan is
hysterical we were laughing we were all
laughing about it this morning
um but it takes about two and a half to
three hours per location so I'll shoot
three locations in a day so we did three
yesterday uh three today and then we
bounce out and then Monday we'll be in
Nebraska uh doing doing a whole nother
run how difficult is it to eat on camera
um well it just depends on what level of
starving you're at you know so if you're
coming in now that was that was my third
location so I had already eaten at two
locations prior which by the way this
this Connecticut Greenwich area has got
the Stanford has got a fantastic
bandwidth of restaurants I mean this the
gym membership should be blowing up by
now
um but it's uh it's it's the key is is
not taking too big of a bite so you can
actually articulate a conversation
um and it took a while to learn that
because I could fill my mouth up pretty
good with a you know with a slice of pie
okay what happens when and you're nice
you're a nice guy
but when you do bite into something and
you're on camera
and then it might not be as good as
advertised or your favorite so how do
you do that in a respectful way well
fortunately that you know it just like
with what your team does with you is
gives you some insight to us getting
ready to happen
um or I think that's what goes on you
know over at your uh your chaos uh my
guys we're aware of what's going on I
see the recipes before I go there I pick
the recipe I pick the menu items that I
want to try I've got a pretty good idea
of what's getting ready to happen now is
there a difference between good great
and blow your mind yes
um good gets I I I like it it's it's
good you know this is I like this part
of that part
um great usually gets a little bit more
of a delay and blow my mind is you know
I'm scarfing the whole thing down until
my co-host steals the lampshank yes I
did I mean Dan I'm gonna tell you what
we ate yesterday on that lamb shank was
probably one of the best lamb shanks
we've had on the show and I've done 1500
locations so it was that was pretty out
of bounds and so it's kind of that thing
we don't get ourselves in that situation
anymore where I'll get to a location and
it'll be a big whammy that like they
completely screwed this up or sold us a
bag of beans that that that doesn't
happen anymore do you have food rules
like do's and don'ts like ketchups on
ketchup on hot dogs or ketchup on eggs
or like is there anything where you go
that's a that's a no-go non-starter I
don't
faking it you know I'm not a big fan of
you know some of those Maneuvers
um I think that even truffle oil for
instance I think that you know it's not
something I use but if somebody wants to
use it and they don't use it as perfume
I'm okay don't overdo it but otherwise
you know each to their own enjoy it I'm
just what I'm really into is
authenticity you know we just shot a
place this morning uh here in Greenwich
that makes their own pasta and this
guy's from Italy he and his wife are
from Italy and they make outrageous
pasta and then you can also eat some of
the dishes there at their uh at their
you know pasta shop
and just going there they put five
ingredients in one dish and it just
tastes like an orchestra of flavor so
when people are doing it simple and
doing it right like this pizza joint I'm
at today I wish I'll I'll send you a
text and tell you where it's at because
these dudes are doing it right you know
less is more and technique quality
ingredients and passion for what they're
doing makes all the difference in the
world well it's great seeing you
yesterday got to see the Camaro and uh
when are we going back to work together
because I'll get rid of this gig in a
second because you make real money on
that show you got you got your own
tequila and you got I mean you got
things going on here yeah well I I think
that you've been a great example for all
of us to follow do what you love to do
surround yourself with great people uh
and and entertain folks and you've been
doing such a great job of it so I'm not
and I told you this when we met a long
time ago anytime you want to do this now
that means I have to come back to
Connecticut more often I think you owe
me a trip to Northern California So
Random right you know round up your
circus get all your crew together which
by the way guys I sent you a bunch of uh
of uh Diners Drive-Ins and Dives
t-shirts so if those didn't make them uh
I know the dance you know no I have them
I got I got the you you signed a poster
to me where you you you signed it to Dan
I don't know what to say thanks I guess
like that didn't really resonate with
we've we've we're friends like he's
inviting me to his Ranch he goes oh you
got to come out I got a guest house here
oh let me sign a poster and I go okay
and then he goes to Dan I don't know
what to say thanks I guess yo listen he
is hanging me out the dry so bad on this
right now because I asked him I said
right here guys because you know how he
has his one-liners and all I said and
he's in my ear write something like ah
Dan you did terrible I can't write that
you know then you're the best you should
take over my show I'm terrible I mean
he's running one-liners at me the whole
time so uh thank you I guess was my uh
trying to be funny but now you did a
great job and uh we we appreciate you
making it in any time when does that
episode is that in the fall that that's
coming out it could happen it can air
anywhere from two months to six months
but I'll let you know when it's getting
ready to to happen and you can uh you
know send it out there and I'll send you
I'll send you a clip that also so you
can you can have it but yeah it was a
lot of fun you left you said hey I hope
I did okay and I looked at my team and I
said that guy crushed it right it wasn't
just me and Fanboy that you know Dan was
here like no it was hysterical we're
sorry it was just such a short piece did
you do New Haven pizza have you done
Sally's and Peppy's yeah we were going
to go up to New Haven but Yale's
graduating
um so this was uh this was a tough time
of year for us to make it up there man
you know what that's where I do my
Encore in New Haven
yeah
God that that'd be that'd be great make
a note of that when we come back in 10
years New Haven fantastic 10 years I
think despite we're jotting it down
right now the whole crew's here yeah
they're they're all standing by waiting
for this we're in the middle okay my
sorry guys sorry guys buddies from
yesterday by the way I yelled at one of
your cameraman because he yelled at me
while we were shooting yesterday I said
stop yelling at me yeah well that's you
know we just trying to make you feel
like you're at home
I am the deputy mayor of flavor town
just want to let you know okay terrible
we we should Knight you in some yeah
thank you that you are you are now
Deputy Mayor you have license yeah
thanks safe travels and again thank you
thanks again DB next Guy Fieri Diners
Drive-ins Dives and Dan